ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
je
aujourd'hui je me rends à la capelle
dans le département de l'aisne
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
dorothée c'est moi enfin chanté et
enchanté
merci merci nous recevoir mais je vous
en prie dorothée il ya du désordre ici
oui je suis en plein rangement et un
rangement tout ce qui est à la hausse et
tous les vêtements que je dois vendre de
ma fille qui est beaucoup trop petit
puisque financièrement c'est très très
très très compliqué donc j'essaye de me
faire de l'argent comme je peux vous
travaillez oui le temps se dit tout à
fait juste serveuse au grand cerf
d'accord donc c'est fermé avec le co
vide et vous en sortez pas votre votre
fils est avec vous ma fille chez son
papa en eure-et-loir 380 km d'ici elle
vit avec son papa elvis et le pic en a
la garde et donc votre fille vous la
voyez pas trop souvent du coup c'est
leur normalement d'après le jugement je
dois l'avoir un week-end sur deux plus
soit la moitié des vacances soit les
vacances entière mais là
ma dernière visite remonte au 27
décembre que je les ramener chez son
papa et je n'ai pas pu aller à voir
parce que je tombe en panne de voiture
malheureusement comme moyen de
locomotion ma situation financière est
une catastrophe
je suis sorti de l assistante sociale
hier encore qui vont peut-être m'aider
pour financer de l'essence pour aller
chercher ma fille la prochaine fois
avec l'ajout depuis huit ans et elle
m'appelle way s'est régulièrement
comment ça se passe les cols ces
activités est à côté et surtout quand je
lui aurais recherché c'est très très dur
si vous parlez trop de ma fille j'ai les
plus riches non c'est pas c'est pas le
but alors aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre
programme
j'ai bénéficie d'un secours populaire à
fourmies donc j'ai le droit de colis par
semaine ça ça vous êtes beaucoup oui mon
frigo est plein mine de rien grâce à eux
on va y aller ensemble comme ça vous
allez nous nous expliquer tout ça
donc là vous allez récupérer les colis
c'est ça oui rocher kings ont donc c'est
quoi c'est une fois par mois
c'est une fois par mois ça nous coûte 13
euros 13 euros mais vous avez beaucoup
plus de choses les féculents des boîtes
de conserve
les surgelés les produits laitiers du
lait des céréales à gros coup à ben
voilà oui mais voilà le papa bonjour
monsieur
donc vous allez à mener votre fille donc
là où ce conte populaire c'est ce
qu'elle vient de me dire oui à former
des fondements qui a combien de
kilomètres d'ici 2 km
donc il faut une voiture quoi tu 300
russie l'abbé raté je vais monter avec
vous comme ça je me mets derrière
là
donc dorothée vous venez depuis le mois
de juillet oui grâce à papa
grâce à papa voyez-vous monsieur vous
venez depuis plus longtemps
plusieurs années plusieurs années oui
vous êtes à la retraite
disons en invalidité pertes d'emploi à
cause du cartilage de raisons de santé
le coeur tout comme le métier ouvriers
en à bonn en abattoir vous veillez à la
voiture arrive c'est assez physique
assez physique et donc vous avez une
pension d'invalidité wall est vraiment
minime minimes et dont vous pouvez pas
joindre les deux bouts
non c'est impossible celui qui dit qui
arrive je sais pas comment il fait
on essaye de s'en sortir mais c'est dur
on réforme m mais c'est limite limite
ok vous dorothée en fait vous vous
expliquer que malgré votre travail
malgré votre contrat vous touchez
combien ce n'est pas indiscret bralo ce
mois ci à 1211 1211 euros vous avez une
pension alimentaire à payer vous versez
votre mari de 120 euros
j'ai un loyer intégral pour l'instant un
loyer de combien 450 j'étais crédit oui
crédit à la consommation toutes les
charges à côté l'électricité l'eau
bah les assurances voitures senti mon
téléphone il me reste en gros 100 euros
pour vivre désolé du terme c'est marche
ou crève en fait pouvez demander à papa
je ne mange pas comme je dois manger
si j'avais un repas par jour c'est très
bien voire pas tous les jours une fois
qu'on est salarié on a droit à une chose
qu'on va aller voir le président de
cette association qui est aussi le
président de secours populaire parce que
c'est pascual c'est ça pascal c'est une
figure locale ici oui méconnu de partout
allez
la coupe du monde
bonjour bonjour bonjour quand allez-vous
bien très bien
vous êtes pasqua je suis vous vous êtes
connu comme le loup blanc ici
apparemment c'est gentil jour ça va vous
ça va alors là on a 90 bénévoles et
aujourd'hui c'est 350 familles que nous
sommes en train d'aider en produits
alimentaires
vous êtes le président d'une association
oui il arrive à la crécelle les
pascrécelles et notre activité
principale c'est la danse en claquettes
en claquettes voilà et et comment on
passe des claquettes alors allées
dallées de l'hilarité la solidarité
c'est parce que lorsque vous faites des
spectateurs vous faites payer là la
séance est pas faire de l'argent donc
nous avons décidé d'aider les autres
d'accord d'accord
la solidarité c'est la base de toute
société correctement menée gérer les
marchandises elles viennent d'où alors
les marchandises viennent des grandes
surfaces
si vous n'avez pas les supermarchés qui
jouent vraiment pour le coup le jeu vous
n'avez pas d'aidé alimentaire ils ont
des marchandises au lieu de les jeter
préfère me les donner à ce que vous avez
aussi comme ça de plus en plus dans les
profils j'imagine que vous les
connaissez tous et que vous les suivez
des travailleurs pauvres des gens et si
vous voulez actuellement regardez je
vais vous montrer là c'est que vous
voyez les colis qui sont là c'est pour
rien que pour des travailleurs pauvres
quand vous êtes malheureux vous avez
l'appel vous avez là
assez ému vous avez énormément de monde
de pie xii le pape d'un machin qui vous
aident quand vous êtes salarié vous avez
pu rien d'être fichu vous êtes bien et
le gant en tout cas pascual mais je
pense que désormais mairie vous avez
fait quoi dans la vie
les pilotes de chasse pilote de chasse
ah oui d'accord et je vais vous montrer
notre activité tous et sa classe et pour
les sans abris et les sans papiers à
paris parce que je m'occupe des sans
papiers qui sont très mal accueillie
aussi donc je vais dans les portes de la
chapelle et c'est pour essayer de leur
tendre la main
c'est important quand vous impliquer sur
ligne pour les migrants par exemple vous
fait pas de politique
c'est ça pour vous c'est la l'humanité
qui prime il faut aider les gens qui en
ont besoin
où ils en ont besoin c'est ça votre
crédo c'est ça c'est ça et si vous
voulez moi je pense que les élus si vous
leur apportez rien il s'en moque il
tourne la page vous n'existez pas et ce
qui est ce qui est idiot c'est qu'une
région comme la nôtre a besoin
d'associations comme les nôtres donc le
jour où nous aurons risque de
disparaître
par exemple ici à fourmies vous avez 400
familles qui n'ont plus est c'est cette
chaleur humaine
ce sourire cette main tendue vous
comprenez et ces élus là ne le
comprennent pas ça des jeunes filles
comme dorothée vous en voyez beaucoup
oui
ce qui me rassure c'est que ils se
sentent pas va baisser ici dans cette
association recevoir de l'aide a accepté
de recevoir de l'aide je trouve que
c'est quand même compliqué si le grand
public parce que je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui sont peut-être nous en mal que
moi finalement
je me dis rien depuis cinq mois qu'ils
ont le droit aussi donc pourquoi pas
mais bon ça dépanne énormément merci à
temps vous savez on finit toujours la
séquence par une photo et je vous
suggère peut-être de passer vos bras
auteur de chacun et me voilà après ils
vont tous dire qu on était serrés les
uns que les autres diront ce qu'ils
veulent mais si c'est une famille
je